tonight how special is it to share this
with the family does it make it more fun
or more stressful both both I'm I'm
pulling double duty but I love it I
wouldn't have it any other way yeah you
have two very special performances
tonight I'm excited because I just wanna
pop and lock to your music take a
thought well maybe not that part but be
really easy to take off I know the
shears as as much skin as I'm showing
tonight but uh so can I assume that we
will see you on some skates tonight it's
possible okay
you know we've seen you in silks we've
seen you rigged up and now skates you
really need to give people a reason to
pray you know like two feet on the
ground do you
I can do that too but ama's always lets
me do really wild stuff I was walking to
the elevator at the hotel like a week
ago for Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
the guy that was helping me with the
elevator was like Hey last time you were
here you were hanging on the outside of
the building I was like how many people
do you get to say that to that's wild
that's so wild
um and then also you're paying tribute
to Olivia Newton-John tell us about that
performance and what she has meant to
you in your career she was an absolute
icon she was and also she was a
wonderful human being I loved her voice
my daughter just got done doing grease
in her theater production and she
actually helped me learn the song did
that was she Sandy no she was no
like a show that I'm the youngest person
so I was Ensemble yeah did you love it I
did it I did that same show last year
just Mama me instead of this I love it
well I'm curious who's better at roller
skating you or your mom
probably
um
she's doing a lot of tricks and stuff
with that you must be impressed by her
skating skills yeah
[Music]